out of the state's covet 19 task force  says northern nevada is actually seeing  a bigger surge right now  locally here in southern nevada  hospitals say though they are prepared  for another spike  public health workers are focusing their  efforts on hard hit parts of las vegas  mainly  in the east valley there's also a new  coronavirus test site a drive-through  test site that opens today at texas  station  the testing started at eight o'clock  this morning it'll go until four this  afternoon  happening on the first floor of the  parking garage on the south side of the  texas station property on rancho  all to address growing coveted numbers